[Music]
julia is calling hi
julia how are you hi good afternoon it
is an absolute
pleasure to speak with both of you you
too how can we help
uh forgive me i'm a little bit nervous
but um the reason i'm calling is because
i've been listening to you for a while
i got your financial piece university
and i've been watching those videos and
actually i've watched them twice now
to see if i've missed anything the first
time around
and i've been taking advantage of all
that i'll get right to the point
my husband and i are on baby step two we
have
two debts that we're working on one of
them being
some child support that is in arrears
now the state has ordered that they're
in arrears
um this was done about 10 years ago but
to be honest he doesn't actually owe
them
he is not interested in fighting them
and
anytime i bring it up um
to see about paying you know to to fight
them
he gets very angry he gets very upset
he kind of almost turns on me and i just
let it go we continue to pay as we're
supposed to
uh as the state has ordered but i'm
wondering am i missing something is
there sort of man
code or something that no i feel like
i've stepped
somewhere that i just shouldn't be i
don't have any idea i mean
you might be there might be something to
the story you don't know and i don't
know
but no it's not man code i mean if it's
child support and he doesn't owe it you
fight it
and you uh push back against it and you
win and you don't pay it
if he does owe it you pay it it's really
not much in between
uh but hanging around and paying
something you don't know and being mad
about it for decades is not
i don't get that that's not manchester
united
and it and it was in the baby steps it
would actually come
first the first thing to pay off but in
my heart i feel like if i pay that off
first
or if i start throwing chunks of money
at it and then we do all of a sudden
he wakes up one day and says well hey no
let's go ahead and fight it
well they're going to look at us
throwing chunks of money at it and say
well
you know how much is it what's
outstanding balance
15 000 okay and julia how long have you
and your husband been married
it's actually 13 years today all right
so you guys have been married 13 years
you know what's jumping out at me julia
the singular pronoun should keep saying
you say i
and i if i throw money at it and so you
guys aren't working together on your
money are you
no yeah that's a very uh sensitive top
the whole money situation is very
sensitive and he just tells me to take
care of all of it he makes the majority
of the money and i take care of it
yeah that's unfair to you yeah that's
unfair to you
and see that's the first caveat not
being aligned in it and being able to
communicate about it he's shutting down
all together with money
and now here you're standing and looking
at this and this is a battle that he
needs to lead
on this child support thing but you all
jointly together are doing this this is
something that impacts your future so or
decide
i don't want to fight it i'm just going
to pay it right and then you chunk money
at it don't worry about it but
but i don't want see the problem is you
don't know what to do because you're
afraid if you pay extra on it
he's going to wake up one day well he
needs to be part of the discussion so he
doesn't wake up one day yeah
and so yeah this is um i mean
what i would do on this is i think the
two of you probably ought to sit down
and talk to somebody
like a good marriage counselor i'm not
saying you're about to get divorced
but you're married you're the engine's
running rough and it needs a tune up
and you know i i mean sharon and i spent
some time with marriage counselor and it
saved our lives
kept her from killing me
[Laughter]
we've definitely been down some rocky
roads and he you know he used to be an
alcoholic he quit all that
he's been drive for over two years now
so we we've definitely had some rocky
roads and i think
it's wonderful news and i just i feel
like you know what here's the thing
did he did he do 12-step
no sir he just quit cold turkey he just
quit okay just an activist
i told i gave him an ultimatum okay all
right
well i i think the way maybe this sounds
i don't know
i'm just a guy but it's not guy code
dancer man code answer your question
earlier
maybe the way it sounds is i'm so proud
of you for being dry for two years
and the completion of your
healing in these areas is for you and i
to be on the same page with money
and it's it's i'm tired of carrying the
weight of the household on my back
and i need you to man up okay
and i need you to step up beside me and
say
i i want you to walk with me be my man i
don't want you to carry it all i'm not
gonna dump the thing dump the bills on
on your side of the desk we're gonna do
this together but i
i'm tired of doing all of this by myself
and then that leads into the
conversation on the other but
really the the child support thing is a
symptom of what you called out chris i'm
not working
together yeah and here's the deal he's
got dave old emotions attached to that
obviously to a damaged relationship
pisses him off every time he comes up
absolutely but it's not part
of julia's fault and she's part of the
solution i agree counseling is the way
to go
yeah get get some coaching and just how
to talk to each other but it can start
with
we've come a long way let's finish this
journey
yes because i'm tired
of doing this by myself that's good my
wife says i'm tired of carrying out the
trash it's your turn
she says stuff like that and you know
what yeah she is that she is
she's she's a that's a hill you take out
the trash you're dead gum right i did
i'm scared of her